if I say something like well that's a
really bad luck if I say something like
45 divided by 15 because we did this
just now right think before we were
talking in words right how would you
phrase what this is actually calculating
what would you say anything yet okay so
you're you're going straight to the
numerical like this simplified answer it
is three divided by one but like what
are the verbs remember I said like um a
half times four is half of four yeah so
what words could I use yet today okay I
could say 45 I'm going to break it into
15 I could do that I could also say how
many how many 15 and this is the way I'd
love you to read German how many 15 um
how many 15 are there well how many 15
fit in 45 okay so in other words we're
like let's chunk it up and sure enough
you get three chunks each of this size
that's how many you can get in there so
now if I posed the question 4 divided by
1/2 so I'm doing some division now I've
got some fractions involved according to
this pattern they would notice this
verbalization right what this really
means is how many halves are there how
many halves are there in oh now we can
draw this okay I'd love you to draw it
with me let's draw 4 right so I got 1 2
3 4
this 4 okay and I want to see how many
halves there are okay well I'll go
divide that in half divide that in car
by then half like that hot and I've got
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 right so this is 8 in
exactly the same way I could say 4
divided by 1/3
right that would be how many thirds are
there in for now I'm gonna do this one
across here you'll see why in a second
it is my fault
I'll divide each one into birds such a
thing okay and then you count it now 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 they should
notice this 8 and 12 to be suspicious
right 12 is exactly the same as 4 times
3 right and 8 is exactly the same as 4
times Suh mansard remember what we're
saying out reciprocals right what are
you divide by a number dividing by a
number is exactly the same as
multiplying by its reciprocal
in fact Mennella pointed this out just
earlier 4 times 1/2 that's 1/2 of 4
that's the same as dividing by the
reciprocal these guys are reciprocals of
each other right that's such an
important idea let's write it down right
dividing by a number dividing by a
number is exactly the same is the same
as multiplying by the reciprocal of that
so instead of saying oh what how many
cars are on 4 let's let's draw it and
divide enough I can go straight to
saying that 4 divided by 1/2 is 4
multiplied by the reciprocal of ha
that's 2 straight go to aim right 4
divided by 1/3 is 4 multiplied by the
reciprocal of 1/3 which is 3 so 4 by 3
go straight to 12 okay
this is really useful what we have sort
of these are really easy fractions to
work with how about 4 divided by 2/3 my
brain doesn't think in how many 2/3 can
I fit into 4 doesn't think of that
naturally now I can't count it out but
let's try it
dividing by a number is the same as
multiply by the reciprocal of that
number so the reciprocal of 2/3 is right
3 tick so now I just do multiplication
like I did before right this is actually
4 over 1 so it's 12 over 2 which we can
simplify again whoa all the way around
because the big numbers on the top right
so 6 over 1 which is just 6 ok now we
can confirm that look I already divided
my 4 into thirds right
there's 2/3 there's another 2/3 another
one another one another one another one
right 1 2 3 4 5 6
how many 2/3 are there in 4 heads are 6
of them which division after the pin
around using with reciprocals
demonstrated okay